last Sunday's out the gates good alright
and welcome to punch-drunk sports we're
winners
when do they do we have a great podcast
today one of my favorite people on the
planet I love them with all my heart
stop stop stop say someone else and
Gareth is here - how are you buddy I'm
good Gary's here Gary's here everybody's
exciting us joining us from jou York the
King of the Jews are you we're gonna be
we're gonna be yeah let's here's some
date sorry here's some day to be a San
Francisco
June 21st 22nd 23rd Wow Club Wow how are
your shows they're cops Sam do we packed
it out 350 350
yeah pretty excited about that so one
good 50 yeah yeah I mean like yeah it
was great Oh
Garrett do you have any kid dates coming
up I've got some dates Sammy oh I hear
about him I'll be at the stress factory
in New Jersey June 21st through the 23rd
and then I'll be at Laughs comedy club
in Seattle June 29th and 30th wow that's
great yeah and then the dollops will be
on the doll podcast you can go doll
podcast.com slash twitter and you can
find dates where no there's probably one
there and probably went over there I'm
having one over there well as exhausted
as he was Sam solved the problem
thank you you really didn't want to say
any of those words but dude but yeah I
think there's - laughs Ari there's so
many laughs oh T we're doing dates don't
rule ooh that was one of my days what
day was that
Sam you do you know okay we'll fix it in
post
I'm dude I don't really have any dates
coming up what in the history of
punch-drunk
I just haven't usually you play games -
oh honey you have nothing in 2020 I'm
sure I have something going up what
about Saturday night you've conquered
Holly Oh Saturday night it is the
punch-drunk UFC 225 viewing party at the
sycamore tavern it is no cover to get in
there is free parking and we have our
good friend Mickey gall showing up to
hang out eat drink laugh have a good
time we're getting the whole side corner
yeah so if you're a punch-drunk fan come
up to us tell us you want to be that
you're here for the Hangout and view and
we're gonna have a great time because
they don't think it's a good card I'm
super excited yeah this had to talk
about that I got a few dates guys it's
gang fest obviously all three of us are
at skank fest I can't wait to talk about
basketball cuz Jeremiah Watkins just
broke his arm oh [ __ ] and that's the guy
that we oh we can't guard him can't
guard him don't have to worry about it
now it's gotta be red band dude gotta
it's gotta be he broke his arm yesterday
skateboarding Wow he's in a full left
right arm cast full right arm cast saw
us he viewing parties going to be good
USC viewing party that's so come
Saturday that'll be fun then I'm at
flaccid Frank's all weekend it's not a
comedy club it's some limp-dick guy I
met on snapchat who's paying me and
Bitcoin to straighten out his piss pomp
I'll be at Nana Nana boo boo sticking my
head and dude you on the 4th of July or
anything nothing and then once again I'm
glad to be back so guest list on that
looking yeah if you're there one I'll be
on oh I'll be on a corner of Lybrand
Hollywood singing the national anthem
tonight sometime around 3:00 today
tonight in the morning and right around
there sick agita
and then finally I'm finally it finally
is folly for it so finally I'm at
finally spot
finally I'm at [ __ ] fun take your time
finally I'm finally at I'm nervous about
finally spotting sort for for Friday's
following fun Fridays
fort frolic Florida jig that digs either
yep wow thanks that's really great hey
dude I like your jacket
wait I just got a Tripoli sure that what
oh how about his shirt says he won't
fight me
ha ha ha NN for the first 10 minutes of
the show it just had Sam Tripoli so we
thought I thought you supporting me as a
fan as did I yeah I thought you were
supporting me as deny weird when do you
want fight
what if you alright let's do it twenty
nine what did you say September 29 I'll
fight whenever he wants set it up
Tripoli is ready right now set it up yep
and no kneeling Jason we should fight at
Alice mania who me new I'm already at
cornering uh O'Neill so you can't fight
too
you can't find in corner you know the
rules that's how again you're exhausted
for quartering you're gonna fight tapped
out
but we have some great strategies like
we're gonna marinate his gloves and
diarrhea oh my god but just for the
pinkeye a jab in now you got pinkeye you
got a black pink eye kid I was gonna
prompt big guy all right bad news good
news the bad news you're blind in your
now you have [ __ ] in your eye go so it's
not etch in your black eye you'll never
stop guys speaking of blind
nicey-nice do you guys need contacts yes
huh
there's a million things demanding your
time contacts lenses shouldn't be one of
them with simple contacts you can renew
your prescription and reorder your
contacts from anywhere in minutes no
more doctors offices or waiting room or
a pink I know it won't know
it's self-guided takes less than five
minutes
think of how much time you'll save
compared to making appointments getting
to the eye doctor taking time off it's
designed by doctors and license license
factors reviewing every test carefully
to make sure your eyes look healthy and
that your vision hasn't changed simple
contact has all the brand's brands and
lenses you're familiar with so there's
never so you never have to shop around
to find the lenses five stars if you're
shopping around you're an [ __ ] like
you said you can't you can text with the
support team and always get to speak to
with someone in person not a robot now
who wants to talk to a robot Sam not me
with this email in any way just call
them it's really hopefully the contacts
are working it's really in another dude
and you don't have to go take a vision
test take a five it takes five minutes
from your phone from your laptop from
anything you can take a five minute
vision test from your phone or computer
our antlers or your computer re and it's
reviewed by a licensed doctor you
receive a renewed prescription and they
reorder your contacts right there
all you need is your current contact
real doctors of course they are re Abudu
doctors so now chickens cut heads up
look you can see good leave the bottom
line doctor it's not dr. J drink this
blood and read them all dr. Dre okay
yeah doctor no Jay no drag no Jay no Dre
guys the vision test is only 20 bucks
you go and did it's it's really easy
contact lenses our prices are unbeatable
standard shipping is free and the best
of all we offer them through this promo
to our listeners at puncture on just go
to ah go to simple content
komm backslash punch-drunk or just go to
the website and enter to punch trunk in
the promo code and get $30 I'll offer
with uh with our unique special
promotion I mean you factor in the
vision test is 20 bucks it's 200 bucks
to go to an eye doctor and get your
prescription read on yeah so it's it's
saving you right there that's I'm bad at
numbers literally 5,000 dollars off you
said you're bad at numbers right at
number thank you nailed it I appreciate
that on there hey guys but make sure
didn't this is not a replacement for
your periodic full eye health exam now
it's just you know if you get your
prescription refilled still go through
periodic eye exam I mean good lord exam
love having mine I make a day of it yeah
whole thing i day yeah i i day Friday I
de yeah Friday I did guys Friday I de
dude so Gareth what's going on in your
world of fun festivities congratulations
thank you yeah baby I had to baby I know
the show the show no relish I got two
babies for doing Arrested Development it
was a it was a whole thing with James
that a maybe baby it's a maybe baby and
what you do is you use the baby for a
month if you're not happy just get send
the babies back yeah and I'm sending him
back I'm not happy with either the baby
baby baby what's that one actor like is
he cool he's really down to earth what
about that one I heard she's difficult
to work with
oh she I mean she is because she loves
the process if you love good stuff then
you're gonna get great you know you're
gonna get someone who what what about
the controversy of diversity not allowed
diversity going on there oh well I think
that's fair what what about Trump he
really [ __ ] her show didn't he thanks
coming on the show dude it's not right
guys great let me know if you want more
nope we don't get all day yeah I was
told that get free lenses Johnny how are
you you're very quiet I'm okay
what are your oh just okay just okay why
what's going on
I'm I'm I'm a little sleepy I'm fine why
are you sleepy well because I didn't get
much sleep that's Rex that that happened
oh [ __ ] I forgot about one date oh man
I'm in spoiler alerts comedy club this
weekend where I saw solo and at the end
of solo everyone dies chibok is gay and
Darth Maul's at the end of it ourselves
I love this dude support alerts god is
any did you love solo you wrote on that
right
I wrote solo alone ironically I don't
know I just wanted a knife and I got a
bunch of spoons tell us about it it's a
process my process for solo was real
easy can you tell us why are you as the
creative process decided to go I am an
actor was that's about six inches
shorter than the original accent actor
who played the role yeah because in
space the molecules are different and
you can absolutely have height and
weight fluctuations it's like walking
through a year actually tolerance you
can be but you can also be smaller both
can happen it depends whether you're
actually taller in space because
gravity's not pulling you well not in
the parts you know about but like again
when you're writing solo you I mean
you're dealing with a lot of different
you know and you're alone as [ __ ] yeah
absolutely alone yeah would you write it
in the cab in okay I'm done answering
questions on solo okay what's going on
with New York dude so are your big
friend a fan and friend of Michelle wolf
Ari I saw the you tweeted some letters
show yeah is that your secret girlfriend
is that just more Jew propaganda
what if that's his secret girlfriend
we've been hearing about oh oh look at a
smile Michelle we call a low three
Aaron breaking news I didn't know that
that was just little side piece who's
here looking in the side pieces yeah bye
Felicia
[Laughter]
[ __ ] these guys so morning nanny do you
need contact lenses news Ari
Johnny's rocks
Johnny's walking out holy [ __ ] that's my
ride home Johnny you're back I did
wonder what happened
breaking news hey Ari we got breaking
news from fight mark not really breaking
news it's breaking news oh it's not it's
not true and I knew it wouldn't be true
cuz he really is a sweetheart so I did
text him like right away and I talked to
his manager right away break it's not
true his manager too like his like
Instagram is my team at social we're
gonna go see a ton of screenshots of
like proof and like people to have
stories about what this girl has done to
him did you hit him up going hey is he
available I did not so this girl I
should I say her name but she's nuts
when I was with him they're like she
would send like 50 videos a day of her
like threatening him yeah and she was at
Claire's got a vlog she was at clubs and
we would see her we would leave the club
because she's don't like throw drinks at
girls so I was like scared of this girl
when I was there
well you're the fight nanny you know how
to fight right no you don't punch
glasses yes I know you can fight good so
I text him and I said this isn't true
right it's that girl and then he said
yeah and then I talked to his manager
and it was and then she
institutionalized herself after and
feels really bad but I don't know if
she's gonna drop the charges cuz she
really is like insane and she like said
she was gonna there's like videos of her
doing this and
messages saying like I'm gonna call the
cops like I'm gonna kill myself what I
was doing bad but he's annoying and he
probably won't show up - he has a court
date on Thursday he probably won't show
up and his manager saying that she was
like can you guys picture Nick Diaz like
going to police station and signing
paper like he's so hard to work with
yeah
how does he make money he doesn't he was
broke when I was there like he gives him
money something he gave him like thirty
dollars one time it was really sad it
was like $30 hold you over for the day a
lot of money when you don't have ask
Nate Diaz for $30 a quarter
why are you talking the second memo okay
yeah but I was learning or you guys
didn't talk about it and I'm glad I
could tell you well because we wanted to
talk to you cuz that made the inside
scoop yeah and I want to tell you how
weird he is that he goes really emo on
Mila any messages you do like what does
that mean we're black on the outside
it's how I feel on the inside it was
more black shirts than Tripoli hey can I
borrow some money for clothes and these
don't know I'm like saying everything a
year later like how he was he was he's
nice but crazy
you stole my debit card one night Amy
tonight dude we got that and her game it
tonight he'll I said Jimmy sometimes
like in the middle of the night so I
know he's wasted like 4:00 a.m. and then
he'll delete the messages but you know
on Instagram you can see them like if
you have your notifications on even if
they're data so I'll see them and then
I'll go to read them and their race and
he'll be like come hang out with me I
miss you so much I don't care that you
have a boyfriend and then like
heartbreak emoji he's willing to have an
open relationship with you and then
everyone Brad he's gross so he'll hook
up with anyone anytime and then were
using any time personal by one I was
eight days in a row though Oh like super
guys are married huh did you get half a
[ __ ] half of whatever [ __ ] me I got I
got three hotels that's like what he
gets is free hotel that's how he lives
out there after he told me everything
he's like I don't like talking to you it
hurts me too much
and then he blocked me and he doesn't
he blocks me lon and then on blocks
manifold he's crazy
I've forgiven you so wait a minute so
you're saying a guy who fights in a cave
yeah was suspended for five years
big time yep mm-hmm it's crazy yeah okay
yeah look who's the voice of reason
Aaron Wow well we're sad we're sad that
he's hurting yeah you know it's like
they just had that football player just
went through this the chicken came out
and manually lie up and it's like you
have to pound on these for the night
right for dinner did it almost cost him
so much she literally in the you know
documents or whatever you have I am
going to destroy your career I'm gonna
make sure you never play football again
because you don't love me right about
that chick is she's probably great in
the sack right it's like when you're
that crazy and he's willing to put up to
that you've got an extra gear you're
good no no way I mean I [ __ ] a few
like $50 a week kind of chicks sure and
no no hon who's living who the money is
she giving you the money you're not
saying what the value of the [ __ ] is
like that eight million dollars a year I
feel that we lock you out of eight
million dollars a year
I [ __ ] chicks that could have [ __ ]
me out of 50 bucks a week pretty bottom
of the barrel the bottom barrel girls
can [ __ ] absolutely um yeah it's just
weird I mean I never hear women come out
look out I bet she's great in the sack
hello
and then the one on the left right yeah
you know Ari how come you chose you're
so bring the sack
how come Jews chicks are so greatness
that's her oh yeah that's garbage yeah
you don't get skipped like you go to
jail for that it's the worst thing she
could have done besides not admitting it
so yeah
while she go to jail I think she should
yeah you know the you know who didn't
yeah for sure the girl that lied about
that USC football player yep and then
never went to jail like what she did I
don't believe she did Johnny Q look it
up I felt later on they I hope she did
if she did I hope that she should yeah
she should go to jail if she didn't well
that's frame her yeah if she didn't
let's get marks okay yeah I can't tell
if it but no no become a legal podcast
guys welcome to athletes in the law
Karen talk to me legally is the Greek
freak allowed in this country absolutely
it's that more after this commercial
contact pretty good first segment yeah
what about the Nazi tattoo can we get
into that oh yeah what is up with that
what's up with your Nazi do you know
that she doesn't have one but a you
certain UFC fighters husband does yeah
in his reasoning he's like I can't get
it lasered I can't cover it up it's like
why but he wears a long-sleeve shirt
every day he was in prison a prison tat
yeah okay but he has it SS so he found a
knee has a Nazi tattoo so obviously when
you maybe was a Native American and
that's the son I think he's an ex-cop
who had killed somebody really yeah he
had killed somebody and then went to
jail for that he could easily call and
while in jail had you side with the
skinheads and then got a few prison tats
that are Nazi tats
okay gets out of jail marries exactly
yeah guys we all know you cover your
swastikas with right out Chili Peppers
tattoos yeah fire
hurt hurt that she's like you're all
sensitive ass mofos that's like that's
nice yeah you guys are sensitive
sensitive like a Jew we have an Asian
and a black as a friend yeah yeah is
what you said those are valid arguments
now that works for Roy Moore how can we
be racist and our accountants a Jew I
know
I'll get back behind the curtain I'm not
racist I know a [ __ ] in aspic our
gardeners Mexican vote rhyme or yeah
well that's cool I'm glad they found
each other can't you fight I mean
obviously it's just kid I mean she can
clearly take a punch
[Laughter]
she knows we're all right as butters UFC
does not make she can fight yeah what's
her record nine and two okay at least
she's got nine - she's right third in
the whole world exactly nine and two
she's the greatest fighter we've ever
seen they only come around once a
lifetime
she's Ron Dalhousie yeah there's a hat
now say she Australian Air American what
would make you think Australia where
does trillion come out of that ocean
waters guess I don't know why you just
hear the accent I'm a cowboy but what
else she's from Lucy looks Australians
got little she looks me t all right look
at baked dango like a dollop fan right
not reversal views but still great gonna
wear all Sam's adjectives creepy [ __ ]
rude dude that chick looks nice and
marrow
Oh guys good [ __ ] I should have taken
alive on the air an 888 number was
calling me oh man that would be great
they call back probably Somalian
princess I wish yeah like it's not in
English my question is do both of you
bozos take those calls like me they
leave me a voicemail I think then I
can't tell what they're saying and I do
Lee didn't block it okay
that's a good pal I never if we're
trying to save it on there if it's just
a number that's calling me do you answer
that
oh yeah you're saying yes I know the job
and probably they're sad talk to oh you
assume I just thought you were like
maybe this could be worse so you don't
take my call ever but you will answer
I'll answer it if I know the number I
will not answer that's great don't only
number yes what about a blocked call
like if I block my oh yeah sure yeah you
gotta take those for sure I've got to
take a block numbers right right I know
how to get a hold of you when he needs
us though you call over and over text
your phone yeah we're going for [ __ ]
business dude how about those dollars
maybe we oughta just say how's the
weather are you coming to the the UFC
personal question yeah yeah are you
gonna bring the baby no baby's gonna be
ring girl can the baby fight another
baby we have a thing against babies and
bars I know people do it oh you don't
want to be those parent guys if you're
their guy does it actually has no but
thank you we you know can we a baby's
first song oh this poor baby and now we
got some merch well you don't like to
make baby the baby's first pole holding
her up at the top of the pole Nia let's
go can you go
hello can you go do it baby baby you
know what would happened shoot monopoly
money bills get paid the three of us
babysit for little Maxie's bills get
paid we get our 70% and then y'all are
tight with you choice your baby with a
guy that wears that jacket would you do
that actually that just based on the
jacket yes that's very responsible mr.
banks what about the guy who's
underneath because I know okay yeah no
no let's no we're just going on
and mr. Raju what about the Juggalos dad
over here whoa all right you guys have a
good concert I don't know why him pay
your faces we used to not do that Nayla
having fun
I'll be right at midnight don't [ __ ]
around it's supposed to be Faygo great
that's it you kids making any Faygo
brood are we watching the prelims at
this
yeah we'll sleep over ya know cuz
they're right when it started last time
it was jam-packed so many people are
gonna go there to watch it originally
yeah so let's get like six eight I'd say
yeah our sure the end of Thursday night
are you gonna come in hang out are you
too busy I'm I'll be there for the
Thursday night sort of get the area yeah
why what are you doing on Saturday I got
big plans like man name three things
you'll be doing that day I am texting
with LEM Musk
I'm meeting a bunny that Barney or buddy
a buddy bunny bunny no I'm buying a
bunny
[Music]
you're also texting and I am Elsa
texting the bunny I'm taking Helia and
the bunny and then the third thing is
I'm learning how to make a rainbow in my
house Oh a real one yeah yeah yeah
there's a kid that's not creepy
no yeah there's a kid but I'd love to
come but I use a good punch don't you
get 20% off your rainbow cab
unfortunately my contacts I can't find
them so I'm like well having a lot of
trouble but I'll figure it out I'll just
go to the shop talk to me after the show
I'll go to the shop this contact stuff
it's just like how annoying is it
walking to the show we miss the real how
many nail techs and you have to go down
to the local contact shop I mean there's
no other way so I'm just venting about
that again do we have a contact yeah we
do actually do need my glasses we're
stolen my car was broken into and then
all they stole was my singing class what
is that good
for the same story now take that emotion
and put it in the copy it's two-sided oh
hey I hope you read all that list
hey Candace are you excited for your
first Father's Day are you looking for a
nice gift well why don't you think about
our just around the green one are you
trying to find the perfect gift for
fathers and I was raised by lesbians and
I will buy this for my female father
does your father's love to grill but he
does hassle no siree store what if what
a better way to kick off grilling season
than by gifting oma steaks a Father's
Day packet I got that right hey I mean
it I love it now Ari have you gotten
your package no of course not coz I get
it all sent to me well Johnny Johnny did
you enjoy the steaks Johnny gave the
thumbs up that means you love it's good
I eat them for months I like to say this
Johnny Johnny ate my meat I have a great
time I mean dude it's amazing it's
really Kamil maja steak delivers the
hand trimmed flash-frozen vacuum sealed
meats directly to your door no moss
poultry Billa hmmm they have the highest
quality cuts one-of-a-kind flavors all
the beef is USDA those infected first
quality and ate for 21 days you're just
sitting at a house full of steaks you're
selfish bastard unlocked with full
flavor and tenderness of the cuts do MA
does one of the sidelines at not get
well Wallace takes even gives you the
option customize your cuts for your
dad's grilling needs find recipes wine
pairings
my god even as a grill Wow
but nothing to put on it huh right now
Omaha Steaks is giving me limited time
offer to man our listeners for Father's
Day
that's right 78 percent I because this
is a real amazing deal go to almost
eighty percent off tah type punk shrunk
into the search bar and you can get the
Omaha Steaks Father's Day package a
which package which includes two filet
mignons
to top sirloins for chicken fried steaks
two boneless pork chops all for all beef
Omaha steak burgers for go made jumbo
frets you get like $300 for me freezer
to go all beef wait till mother's
meatballs
one pound of house price for calmer
apples one Omaha they're just doing that
in there to say [ __ ] everything how do
you ship this limited-time package from
we do 49 on it 99 when you go to almost
a candy and a penny punch strong into
the search bar open the Father's Day
package to your car so you guys want to
steal you go to Omaha Steaks calm you
type in punch drunk on search bar and
you can get the deal it's amazing then
you guilt him and make him grilling up
we've heard your story of con artists
guys we love Omaha Steaks re re isn't it
delicious re-use oh you didn't re but
wait oh wait oh ham you're gonna have a
reason to pound the [ __ ] out of him now
is that that's still the case Sam say it
off mic so alright I was I was I was
prepared to come here and discuss with
the two of you about this three-on-three
thing they were talking so much [ __ ]
about you Sam
three three on three one okay yeah yeah
and I'm like do you know and I'm telling
Josh Martin all these other people I'm
like do you know how dirty the three of
us are gonna play oh you can say as much
as you want about you're too old and you
guys bah blah we have unlimited fouls
and you are gonna get elbows everywhere
how do you three of us share my how do
you dare Maya broke his arm
I [ __ ] followed him just walking down
the highway that way so just a high five
that was just a high five and then
they're like you guys cannot stop
Jeremiah he's too young
he plays basketballs I'm like we play
basketball all of us like you guys are
too old and I'm like we are gonna
[ __ ] be the dirtiest people in this
three-on-three tournament that you've
ever seen what happens there Superstar
breaks his goddamn arm and now what are
you can Jerry Maya is your superstar you
are in trouble they guaranteed they
guaranteed that we finished last out of
the four-team tournament okay first of
all I'll never lose to anybody called
come town I go I go I go back you guys
want to go show to show bag of bats no
and then Josh Minds like no not gonna do
I'm like that's right cuz you wash your
face with our comm you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
last time you talk [ __ ] you got a face
full of calm the simulation is broken
can we agree it is we had a good run
though huh
so now what now I mean what scale Tony
gonna do now it's Josh Martin and it's
uh they're probably gonna go with the
drummer from the band they're not
letting red band still no red man should
have to play ribbon I don't get it
yeah he's the me like me 20 of the main
people it should be Tony red band and
Josh Barton
I mean Redmond has a heart attack when
you give them a two-handed bounce pass
yeah red bands clutches his chest yeah
let it rest let him rest no I do we
should have the ref ban I think Lygia
scary
should make a call and be like red band
has to play you guys are doing this in
New York that's yeah yeah by the way I'm
coming I don't know why you guys haven't
invited me but I'm coming and I do this
ring re a steak or two well yeah yeah
you want to play sure thank god I'm out
guys I'm excited as we're bringing the
baby but we're gonna work in shifts but
also Jeff's mom might go to New York to
watch her so we can have fun i-i've been
seen a lot of Twitter war right now
between yes between your man in
particular
no money like [ __ ] you guys know yeah
yeah yeah he like said yeah they're
going at it yeah it's really raising the
stakes I imported a cornering O'Neill
and we have some incredible strategies
that we've been working on first of all
we discussed earlier do you know the re
can't do it cuz he won't fight me
soaking his gloves in diarrhea that's
gonna be I was ready to fight you
September 29th when they said we all
agreed and then suddenly you had to move
it so when you knew so go through they
go through the mindset of that yes how I
move Jason else's show tell me about it
tell me tell me how what no break it
down like in your oh you move it to
there Wow show me [ __ ] dick
counselor oh okay I like that
something got all I can't you fight at
the end of September I can fight now I
can fight tomorrow I'll fight a week
from now I'll fight a month from now
I'll fight any time this guy keeps he
calls up his [ __ ] agent Gaad hey dude
we got this fight coming up can you book
me somewhere that's not near where the
Fight Club I'm like I can't I'm fighting
Sam Triple Eight they almost had
Coughlin O'Neill saying I think it's
like what are you talking about we said
in a podcast September 28th when would
is that true do not tell me wait he
can't hear you he can't hear you and he
doesn't like you I don't like help dude
everybody knows you're running from me
you're the one who doesn't want to fight
I'll fight anybody
[Laughter]
maybe I'll fight to fight nany I'll
fight the baby you fight the Fox it came
out of once maybe one man enter maybe
she shouldn't come to skank fest skanky
baby I think it's appropriate that your
baby's first thing to go to is skin we
do baby a [ __ ] stamp
oh they grow into those very nicely just
going to New York and she speak at one
of them okay cool okay so hey Johnny we
have to figure out the bag of bat
situation cuz there's a bunch of stuff
there's people on it I'm gonna shove a
hot dog on my half in the corner in the
corner why Johnny watches you got okay
Johnny with a [ __ ] hot dog up my
[ __ ] all right what oh you know I
budget is a lot more than elected won't
any of your porn friends do let me ask
ya that's like very good point you
should have someone in here to make sure
you know someone who can do this get
kobayashi okay what I'm gonna hit up is
my friend Anna ZZ you'll do it he bleep
stories [ __ ] hello
I think I got my shovel [ __ ] hot dog
up my butt see if she'll do it to me too
we just said who owes what I'm bag of
bats Johnny can you do this
okay so I Oh website was supposed to go
up April 1st you [ __ ] liar I only
alright do we still not have a website
sorry
REO Swansea owes to get the suit did the
bus chanting USA beg for our - how much
money - gotta make 50 bucks 40 bucks and
then I thought law shove a hotdog up his
ass we could ask Nate Diaz Oh
Jason knows okay so is anyone argued
with any of this so far have I stayed
anything isn't true
no okay so we all agree I Oh hot dog up
my butt yeah
ah Rio's okay I stuck up your butt
chanting USA in the bus and begging for
$50 okay that's why you're legal you're
here okay yeah nice try Samuel all right
oh that's actually a very hard one and
then yeah you got it back so those are
the three that's why you harder what it
does Tebow oh let's go through an Ewok
trainee walk walk shock collar during an
entire episode shock collar and he owes
people the the jerking off why why
people why people watch what was the
exact ruling on that I have this I have
to be on skype and I have to come live
on the show while on skype looking at
you guys
now I will slightly protest this one a
little bit
what do you mean Skype me sitting here
Jackie
nope I'm sigh I don't show up I don't
show up to that episode I'm on skype
instead of Ari and I am jerking off the
entire show until I come the entire show
and the final to take you to it and if I
don't come I keep doing it until I
actually can come so I could be two
months on skype beating off for two
straight hours into time hey where's
Chuck
mike is a little worried about that Mike
oh you've talked to legal about this
yeah I mean it makes sense he's like I
don't want to lose all things comedy
entire so what we'll do with that
interesting we're gonna set him up like
an account on like chatter Bader's but
nothing like that here's my other where
you can live stream here's where I get
here's right get pissed about this one
okay there's a shitty fan who now is
happy this is what he wanted this is
exactly what he wanted you to pay off
your back no no no he wanted exactly
this because he kept for about a year
and a half kept messaging me if you
don't you should pay off this bet and I
oh [ __ ] I forgot that's like a year ago
I forgot about that one I'll bring it up
on the show next week then every time he
gets drunk he I know I'll show you the
messages off here with sin every time
sky you know every time he would message
me he would get hammy like I better see
you come or I'm gonna destroy punch
strong punch drunk does not respond
respond to terrorist threats we do not
do so you do the tears just [ __ ]
yourself yourself so I mean it sounds
like he just is turned on by you all I
have to do it just yeah guy what he
wants all I have to do is just Jason one
load I save the show I don't know but
honestly one I don't know if I can come
just staring and so if the bet doesn't
get paid off until I come yes you're
gonna be I don't I don't I mean I
literally I don't think I could watch
you guys on ChatterBait or whatever the
[ __ ] you're gonna set up so I paid off
until I come
don't check off for like a white don't
hang out well your lady friends and then
watch some porn on the side you can do
Yeah right there also or at least I'll
fake it I mean I will definitely pull on
my dick for two straight hours
that's all I'm Skyy that's all that's
what you got that's all we're asking for
is that you just pull on it and if you
got a fake come a real come whatever but
what if I can make a show of it well
just show us the illusion you'll at
least think I can Copperfield us so so
those are the those are what's left re
this a congratulation terrorists you got
what you wanted are you sure we
mentioned you on the show [ __ ] you
should go on the street and ask someone
if they want to see you put a hot dog up
your ass for $40 you can conflate and I
put a hot dog in my ass too can all
three of us do it save the day it's come
to this
and I feel left out that I don't get to
put a hot ticket laughs you can't I'm
saying you can I don't think you want to
I think you're putting on show do it
when you're jacking off at home on
ChatterBait I'll call your bluff
I'm your uncle Barry I'll be the I've
been practicing without those big
sharpies how about this how about this
there's the ones that you can get a
small sharp em1 here's what you yeah
here's what you can do you don't have to
do you can pay them all off at one time
dress as a trans with a shot color
shoving a hot dog up your ass and we
will call it all even while jerking off
Wade your hot dog in my ass jerking off
on skype as a [ __ ] with a shock collar
on yes can I be at least like handcuffed
and tasered too at the same time we're
gonna I mean we gonna have to float it
up to Mike but I think there's no reason
why you should be able to maybe like
shoot me with a pen we do you think we
pitch us in that flicks yeah I think I
I'll be honest like when they come in
for the you know absolutely for all the
shows you're riding on absolutely which
are you ready on now I mean we're right
make you a murderer for yeah yeah yeah
we're writing yeah we're it's about the
last two but yeah that's what the fourth
one is about yeah what what did you use
a dollar yeah yes
why don't what I mean it really is silly
the Omaha Steaks hasn't sponsored this
cabassa
so yeah that's what it we're putting an
Omaha kielbasa in our asses today
look at that nine inches of delicious
pork you should have been a baseball yes
sir nine yeah nine inches that's right
being so stingy bro y'all 13 Omaha steak
this could be like now with ass dog did
you just feel like you're taking a [ __ ]
when you taking the bus looks like you
just did it Jesus look at me it's like a
reverse [ __ ] yeah
it's like you take it you're putting the
[ __ ] back in yeah it's just fun it's
like a reunion
I've been member me I've been making
what I call Lego hot dog hot dog this
big made out of Legos that you can click
on to the other one I just jam it in my
ass yeah yeah I don't know and this is
where the fine Andy tells us about
people who frees her shits and [ __ ]
use them as dildos yeah but I like to
only do that when Steve's here because
he really likes it we live in a [ __ ]
weird world the simulation is broken
yeah what do you think in particular you
just I wrote this question down for you
uh Donald Trump saying because a few of
the Eagles and this happens with every
presidency there are people that like
I'm not gonna go because I don't like
Obama or I'm not gonna go cuz I don't
like Clinton you know everybody that
wins at any sort of championship has to
go to the White House or gets to go
depending on how you look at it how you
look and how one looks at it and but a
couple of the Eagles like I'm not gonna
go Jake long few different ones like I'm
not gonna go Jake I'm not gonna go to
the White House because I don't care
about this presidency whatever and then
Trump saying [ __ ] the whole thing's
canceled now because all of the Eagles
aren't going to come because they don't
believe in my presidency and they don't
respect the flag or the national anthem
that's what he says he cancels the
entire thing which is today it's
probably happening right now and instead
now there's like 2,000 fans that are
Eagles fans they're gonna show up to
watch you know the president you know he
goes it's still happening everybody come
we're all gonna sing the national anthem
today and we're gonna celebrate it so
all the fans is that true on my goddamn
life most of us I didn't hear that well
I'm like yep so today at noon our time
so probably right around now right
around right now yep he doesn't know the
words to the anthem we will proudly be
playing the national
and other wonderful music celebrating
our country today at 3:00 p.m. three
doors and that is that is right now
that's noon today
good so instead of let's say Tripoli
gets to go watch the [ __ ] or Ari
you know Ari gets to go see the Cowboys
you know and and meet a bunch of the
Cowboys at the president's house White
House instead no Cowboys please still
come Donald Trump will be singing the
national anthem and other wonderful
music according to his tweet well I
think he's gonna do the catalogue what
is the question the question is what
other songs should he say well but it's
like I want to sing some [ __ ] that's
bad improv it's yes and okay yes stop
words to stop but but it's something
here's what I find crazy is that he
chooses to make that again about the
national anthem and how NFL players
don't respect the flag or trips yeah and
none of that is about any of that he
really took the oh you unless you have
80 people if you have 80 people on a
team it doesn't matter what if I if I
add a lot of them were right the whole
thing about a small enough number that
would have embarrassed what would have
been great is if there's three and he's
like no this is the most amount of
football players ever at the White House
that's exactly what he we're done I
can't stand don't the NFL just [ __ ]
themselves to this whole thing there's
no other no he bumped him other [ __ ]
league is dealing with this cuz they're
greedy pieces of [ __ ] I'll tell you
what's going on right now the NFL owners
are all 80 this is a money grab and they
think the league's not gonna be around
much longer anyways so they're taking
all the money that they can right now he
also has a massive boner for them
because they wouldn't let him buy a team
30 years ago right right so he came in
the presidency like with a boner for the
end of this is before this was even
before well this they took the money
before he was even a president did so
they were making this political it used
to be like you go to commercial why they
were playing a national anthem but now
this [ __ ] military industrial complex
that makes us [ __ ] everything's gotta
be support the troops join the troops
trying to be a [ __ ] join the troops
you know blah blah blah let's salute
this guy and you're like all that's
nothing to ever do with that whatsoever
cuz that but that is that's what gets
lost because our media twisted into oh
you're not supporting the [ __ ] troops
like no they just don't want to get
[ __ ] beat down by [ __ ] cop yes
exactly right
yep also when you go to a game people do
not respect the nobody gives us [ __ ]
like when you're at an actual game
that's when you piss or buy nachos and
look I love my country but I'm also like
do you they're gonna stand up and
everyone's taking the head like off [ __ ]
I got a [ __ ] hat off for this dumb
[ __ ] but they are they react
they're like stupid they're overreacting
because they don't have the ratings that
they used to have and he made this thing
when he scared the owners and then when
the people go I just want I don't want
to be political I just want
entertainment then don't play the aunt
yeah thanks piece of luck in politics
new by the way that's not like something
which happens ever five years ago via
the US military the government paid the
NFL a shitload of money for certain
teams even yeah it's just stupid and
then he passes out Bukka
I'm telling you these guys know that the
NFL as we know it is in for deep [ __ ] I
got too many problems they came I mean
dude we are
snowflake Society they just got rid of
the bikini contest in Miss Universe
competition a beauty contest
they got part of the beauty contest con
you can't judge somebody those are all
stupid anyway it's fat chicks win again
fat chicks won again - you win again fat
I'd rather watch an ugly competition
there are those kids are ugliest ugliest
[ __ ] you can find you don't mean to
be like but they but they put out but
they will suck the skin off a cold room
without getting a bit let me see it
you know there's a cobra you take a
cobra and then you head in your mouth
and it's just nothing and you're totally
in like wow [ __ ] can suck a [ __ ]
dick coming up next the bikini round no
bikinis for these pigs talking about oh
sorry no bikinis for these pigs see no
more annoying than joy bear Oh bro
garbage hates everything and that
everything [ __ ] about everything it's
like can you imagine who your neighbor
oh there's always notes on your door
about your [ __ ] leaves and [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] anybody watch her that's
why I would all right it skank or
whatever it sounds like so I didn't end
up at a PTA meeting it's like [ __ ]
shoot me what's worse her her Joe hurt
her or the people that pay to see her
exactly oh she's sharted
is there anybody at all good ever on
that show I mean like there's literally
just [ __ ] cakung the last lady I
worked for a while yeah all these shows
all day long look at like new shows
those news comedy shows on what is I
don't even know what they are can we go
can we say like like like I'm what
Twitter on Stewart Oh like those kinda
Stewart how old are you
yeah no but what are they what programs
although show she watches all of them
Donahue Carson's are late again
well don't say anything cuz Ari's
[ __ ] secret girlfriend is [ __ ]
having your own political show Ari how
are they doing that she's worried that
your girlfriend yeah Michelle wolf
already's been hitting it oh yeah it's
me don't wall temple they [ __ ] [ __ ]
today that that's Ari secret yeah he
calls her [ __ ] to Gaza and she's been
talking [ __ ] about everybody
Harry's girlfriend talked about Rosie
here's another area where the NFL I
think is [ __ ] I love this ALS [ __ ]
Dwight Clark just died I didn't even
know Dwight Clark had ALS you know the
crazy thing about the whole thing is is
who made the call what's-his-face Vin
Scully made that catch call how crazy is
that on that catch yeah wow I didn't
know that yeah dude
what a great life that guy had right
since he's like 20 til he's 80 you just
went to a ballpark everyone got the best
seat probably yelled at Mexicans all the
time get out of here yes whites only
Mexicans it's a beautiful day for
baseball nothing went to his final game
and he made us sit through him singing
I'm the wind but you are the wind
beneath my wings
shut up
but he's Tripoli and played it yeah no
sir Scully's new album Thanks doors
got here Mexican my Los Angeles move
Mexican you are the glue beneath my
teeth oh by the way Don last night
friends after
so during friends and family Arsenio
decides like hey I'm gonna go up and do
30 so six people lost a five-minute spot
and that's friends and family and then
during after that the Regular Show dice
shows up he's like yeah I'm going first
oh does like 40 people that had fourth
four or five six you know which is an
early spot on friends and family they're
like I'm out courts like I got five I'm
like oh that's a good spot he goes dice
is on right now by I'm out left people
just left like 40 what do we got the old
school Comedy Store that's one two and I
was a whole line of broken did an hour
back in the day to Rogen
ducati did because am I sure the other
option like remember pleasures like I'm
important as well let me do this
harmonica solo Danny guy the sound guy
would would put him on and then run
across Street the House of Blues lost
about 40 minutes of some band
oh yeah people used to always then he
started going into the rain or the o.r
and he would [ __ ] the o.r up because he
turned the lights up and so he could see
people and it just ruined the vibe of
the room let me ask you this please
and this is for everybody no I know your
answer because your money-grubbing I'm
kidding Oklahoma has a quarterback new
guy who's taken over for the guy that
just got drafted first overall right by
Cleveland so this guy's in 1819
Oh kid okay his name is Kyler Murray and
he's going to be the new quarterback for
Oklahoma supposedly the [ __ ] 18 19 year
old kid gets drafted seventh yesterday
by the Athletics by Oakland oh wow
seventh which equals which in in
money-wise that's seven million dollar
contract for this 19 year-old who's five
foot ten and not an NFL type quarterback
the coach of the Sooners is like oh I'm
not worried he'll be here really [ __ ]
yeah
if you're 19 and you don't have you
don't have the physical body tell you're
not a Peyton Manning or a Andrew Walker
please or Sam Tripoli or anybody like
that yeah and you know you have the body
type that's like your oh yeah maybe you
could maybe get switched over to
receiver or something you're one of
those guys I the [ __ ] do you go to
Oklahoma get your [ __ ] tackled and
beat the [ __ ] up or you go to Oakland
live in California I'm 19 and I have
seven million dollars I'll take what's
in the box let me - I've got behind door
number one yeah is there any way you
play quarterback no I'd say baseball I'm
like I don't even got to do it I'm going
for the Oh cliff or neck netting nobody
gives a [ __ ] and calimary you commit
fully a football you go get the signing
bonus and then you're like oh turns out
now
baseball look how he's throwing that
ball he doesn't even have his fingers on
the laces like you should know this
guy's a bozo gay pride does that every
throw I know what an idiot hold it like
the other way I'd love to go watch him
play and we can get your tickets that
seeking everybody does that nice for all
of your ticketing buying tickets can be
complicated and confusing but there is a
better way to buy with seeking seeking
is the smartest easiest to get tickets
to every type of live event whether
you're searching for last-minute deals
planning a night out with friends or
just need the perfect gift gift see can
you imagine planning a night out with
friends yeah I can't imagine
fully guaranteed there's nothing quite
like being there in person and SeatGeek
will get you closer to the action for
great value i've Sikhi got my phone it's
by far the easiest way the shop for
tickets I can be anywhere anytime with a
few taps I can instantly get fine
seating I actually nickel and maybe you
seek to buy tickets for Johnny's getting
tickets for Dodgers or Braves and buy do
boxing is coming dude look up boxing
dude Google boxing what is it google it
I think it's like a company the boxing
what are you ok seeking saves you time
and money by searching multiple ticket
sites to compare prices get the most
bang for your buck with Sikhi greats
every ticket based on the value to help
you immediately identify the best seats
to fit your budget and budget Plus every
purchase is fully guaranteed so you can
shop for tickets on seeking with
confidence makes eek-eek your go-to app
for finding the best deals on every type
of ticket from sports concert comedy and
theatre the most you could re get some
steaks through SeatGeek I think he can
what about what about my desires can get
our listeners to get $20 off the first
seeking purchase just download the app
to see keycap and to the promo code
punch-drunk one word and you'll get $20
off your first picture yep purchase boy
Wow let's say you find out let's say
you'll find a concert ticket or a
baseball game and tickets for 15 bucks
guess what that's free really if you're
not good puncher wow wow they actually
owe you five bucks they will send you a
five dollar bill with just a stamp on it
just reading now see geeks out of
business just right yeah they folded
their business model was flawed I got
can't be right you're sending them here
five dollars who wanted to see did you
guys see that bare-knuckle boxing you
know oh I did I was awesome
did you I just saw how Jeff showed me
highlights that's all in watch
highlights what happened was this legal
Google boxing by me origin I tell you
there was some it was brutal yes it was
like you're just like Oh a doctor had to
stop a fight because one day before
Rawlings is now the champion there she
got dropped by the UFC and robbed
because she lost four in a row yeah I
love the best let me ask you something
it makes sense though she's a
bare-knuckle boxer champion now right
laughs it's her personality
she's a bareback boxer that's a good
that's risky
you know gay porn is coming with that
bare-knuckle boxing bare-knuckle
bareback bare-knuckle [ __ ] stop
Manning me keep plugging away can we
please call this episode bare-knuckle
[ __ ] so bloody it's how this is
to truckers on math 1 that's exactly
what lot lizard who wins that is two
truckers fighting lot lizard that looks
like everything Bulls getting his ass
beat lemma chewy from the county sure
that looks like chewy with that is bolo
hat no neighbors
yeah two guys both fight about a tree
that won't get cut down
what's that 44 there of men because
you're in a room with three of them look
at this guy and I don't want to see you
machetes out there throwing this is life
Jenny che just out of [ __ ] options
Shetty dude this is the equivalent of
[ __ ] hardcore gangbang porn right
this is the male version of it
holy [ __ ] I want to get these people on
the show I like to buy into this can I
buy into this I just it breaks my rule
of athletes which is I I need [ __ ]
[ __ ] I need facts no [ __ ] tits dude
let's keep this going this is not the
sport for you then Sammy watch right
here here Garrett's watch right here
watch him like lean on the thing is like
if you had a cigarette right here be
great get a quick Ripper dog let me get
my one hitter real quick and then we'll
go right back to the action
each fighters allowed nine timeouts
around No
hey dog how does my hair Oh God look
it's like a circle it smell yeah it's a
circuit again yeah like some weird pagan
god they find in this earth - God came
and rain fire on earth for 5,000 years
all you wanna meet me in the
parallelogram hey we're fighting in the
rhombus tonight Jesus dude I hate when
you see a triple back it's a good thing
they're so fat to protect this sponsored
by WorldStarHipHop hey dog no hit backs
hey dog welcome to Gino Dali he got his
finger through it that's fine okay
that's fine that's fine
oh are you into this fight it's like
uncle fighting why do you only like MMA
it is uncle fighting this is like I
don't know
welcome to the tul the drunk uncle
League all right it's uncle Dara
uncle there's uncle girl drunk uncle
League they're living at each other
about something neither can remember
also UFC fighters are better looking
than that fight that's going on this
week do 25 in him everybody please come
hang out watch it with us
I am definitely rooting against
Covington just because of how much he's
talking he said so much [ __ ] about Rogan
that I want him to lose and then I went
Rogan to have to interview him after
Allah yeah what's he say about Rogan you
just talk [ __ ] about I'm gonna find him
I'm gonna find him and I'm gonna slap
him across his face
he guarantees he is showing up to 225
searching for Rogan and when he finds
him he says he's gonna slap what it
drove into it and just say
all Rogen's because he said he was gonna
[ __ ] him [ __ ] up John Jones and then
broken on his pockets goes hey Covington
you better be cool man cuz John Jones is
like one of the baddest brother brothers
on earth mhmmm be careful what you're
saying because you know you might not
and then this guy went on a tirade
looking for rights against argues
against everyone for press on inside
like every time us he posts a picture he
talks [ __ ] and it's like why you're
gonna fight a 1:55 the problem with him
is he's gonna learn the hard way that
he's not gonna make any money in this
business I don't think he will he's
trying to he's trying to be the new
Connor I got him a title shot look at
who's this who's the black guy LeBlanc
here that used to fight GSP all the time
oh right
Koscheck yeah yeah that guy maiden like
I've met that but that was before that
was before he is a dick that's before
pre Connor that was pre Connor but
Connie is he different
Connor talks himself up you know talks
itself up and within like within the
realm of promoting a fight this guy just
[ __ ] shits on everybody yeah I don't
care it's fine
dude if you want to do it that's fine I
think it's funny but I hope he loses the
problem with being a heel in MMA is
there's no you're not making enough in
the fight game you have to make money
boxing I mean you have to make money
through sponsorship and who's gonna
sponsor he'll because no one's gonna buy
the product of a hit walk wiser but why
is this gonna sponsor heel hey man I'm
begging all these [ __ ] and Brazilians
you guys are [ __ ] animals I love
Budweiser I mean that doesn't make any
sense you can't make money on sponsors
anywhere anymore well that's where the
UFC [ __ ] up that's where they
incentive to fall in line you can't make
any money in sponsorship so like why
would he fall in line he's like I'll
make whatever I make regardless I'll
make my money a pay-per-view
I didn't say like we
you to sponsors other he gets based on
how much the pay-per-view numbers he
gets is and then it's like [ __ ] off
everybody I'll just agree with you a
little bit right I mean a little bit
I'll disagree with you right there Ari
when you say you can't make money in
sponsorship because if you're gonna
watch this fight you should bet on it
with our good friends at bet TSI
everybody fat TSI use the code punch 25
and I get you 25 free bucks to gamble I
do $5 fight parlays all the time are you
do can you will you announce your parlay
right now that you're gonna right now if
you guys feel froggy if you feel froggy
go to bet TSI calm use the code punch 25
and throw that 25 bucks on what Sam's
betting right now and now you'll have
the same parlay I'm gonna have the same
parlay as us and then you can watch our
fight companion and win money and
they'll double whatever you put in you
put in 50 bucks they'll throw an extra
50 for you yeah that goes to charity too
does it I don't know I'm not sure what
it probably not but go to bed TSI calm
music could punch 25 and that it's so
fun to watch live with him because he's
just stressed out about his early he
doesn't care about like anything else
that's what happens when you gamble and
it's absorbed I think it's good friend I
think it's good friend guide a guy I
think it's pretty cute so you're gonna
so the part like you're gonna do a bet
decide right now Betty I said calm music
Oh punch 25 you are doing a parlay right
now just on the main five fights right
yes okay let's start with the first
fight Johnny CM Punk is going to lose to
Mike Jackson that's right I think that
as well yes she going are you going that
was in the main name card yeah what's
that
have you seen CM Punk fight well that is
interesting zero inches on his reach so
he has no arms camera he's got McCain
arms yeah yeah
he's an American treasure in here oh yes
thank you for your service John never
squealed
I think Benavidez pettish should be on
the main card not the early prelims we
should switch that hey hey after that
photo you're never in the splash zone
give it give me 20 feet get 20 feet guys
I'm trying to find a key okay thanks for
talking guys I can't right now I need
you to keep doing what you're doing stop
stop keep going guys stop stop stop stop
now what you're doing is good keep it up
keep it up with the same momentum so I I
would go Mike Jackson over simple re
same for sure yep bye mommy
yeah okay they're both record is oh and
one and they're on the main card of a
UFC this one's tough because what he
sells once you get into heavyweights
you'd never know and Orlowski is so hot
and cold yeah like remember he lost like
four in a row and we all thought he was
should retired and was gonna die yeah I
bet he's sprung like three wins together
and they're like oh [ __ ] maybe back then
he lost then he started losing yeah you
never know what this guy alright let's
go through this I'm gonna [ __ ] this
guy alright let's start the show now
Sam's ready to speak all right from the
top wrap everything we just said read -
Sam Sam who do you think to win Yoel
Romero or um my uncle
all right how dare you Johnny
change it crawl over over this what's up
why are we talk about this dumb card and
not talking about the [ __ ] NBA Finals
or the NHL Finals we'll get there
[ __ ] we talk about the NBA Finals
for the last nine hours out of the halls
where I'm like I greet that's weird
I mean he literally was NFL tackle yeah
and then he stands up like how is that
not even
what happened I'll call travel something
out yes something happened
yeah something illegal I am on the
ground everyone's on the ground it's not
travel or a foul jump up no call no call
no call and then the coach is like
what's a [ __ ] technical legal in a
game it's that close that's very
difficult
he wanted me a guy's so alright rere
breaking news that yeah he's moving
we have punch up we have breaking news
on puncher we're breaking news on punch
we have breaking news with Irish smile
every time we tune but we do have
breaking news Ari Shaffir and especially
how long it takes I know I think we have
breaking news or just breaking you if
there are severe Sam Tripoli this is
breaking news big time
Sam Tripoli doesn't want to talk NBA
right now and actually wants to go back
to the UFC brief who you guys thinks
gonna win between dos Santos and that
covington dos anjos yeah Rogan is not
gonna interview Covington at Covington
loses of course if he wins he has to
Covington is horrible if you wouldn't
sloppy they're like no because he'll get
a title shot so then yeah then they will
I think Raphael disown us ones that you
do mm-hmm
it's half al well then I think Xavier
loses yeah because his name is stupid do
you think Xavier Windsor I I do I don't
think I would say his last do you do I
think he loses wins I think you didn't
Covington loses
yes mm-hmm let me do four guys I don't
know why what does Ari think I want to
bet on the ladies day I think the
capture three one they were built in the
year that I was more and they're about
to win their first Stanley Cup title
Meow's it'll blow I mean listen
Megan Anderson because she doesn't even
have a photo that's actually her photo
that's that's how she is it's a lot of
contrast very like it hard to beat our
define right now yeah I feel like next
thing you know you know it's like I
agree though re I think the Cavs that's
the Capitals I think that's it's big
it's exciting I'm excited for Ovechkin
oh she looks like she might be able to
[ __ ] beat some [ __ ] okay dude that's
the Invictus champion is this her first
fight in UFC ah yeah I'm just gonna it
will only let me do a fourth team fight
yes this is our first one okay so that's
it here it is guys
I have breaking Sam Jackson over CM Punk
I have Robert Whittaker over Yoel Romero
oh I have Kurtis plays over over him and
I have our fel dos Santos Ari Megan
Anderson into a field
so is she number one in the world and
his last name Johnson why are you why
he's going against uh Yoel he won the
first one because I don't think no he
didn't Whitaker won did he yeah yeah I
think Whitaker doesn't give a [ __ ]
I think he's not afraid of them that's
my opinion the only person not Freddie
you'll Romero yeah you know you all
Romero's in that gay porn shape so give
it up for him I think they both are
I wish Oh
dolphin everybody's eating but for the
weekend
yeah are the NBA let me just tell you
something our winner who's the time yay
they [ __ ] up that final sequence
during the end of the game won they
should allow George Hill to shoot again
draymond Green stepped into the key
I said hold on they never charged called
the lane violation in the NBA history
yes they should but you could call that
on a lot of free throws you're dead oh
yeah almost all I mean dude Georgie no
loves that JR Smith [ __ ] up
George Hill ever yeah oh yeah nobody's
talking about her missing shot George
Hill is Gary Condit on 9/11 yeah yeah
yeah for sure yeah cuz that I mean that
is like he was like that's not clutch
but then Jerry Smith's like all right
let's game plan I'm here that's not
that's all this Webber to clutch Georgio
call up his agents just start putting
out your Jerry Smith memes left and
right Jake - means means everybody's
mimin but these me men for the weekend
he's been in that song into everything
huh I think he's got a sigh hey dude
look at that
yeah I mean that is pretty egregious
watch watch they say he's yes but yeah
for sure yeah but that happens a lot
and let me say Sam they do all of their
whistles but absolutely vile MBA the NBA
best hope for a competitive series was
for Cleveland to win this game out for
sure yeah I think which is bad usually I
said fix is in I think it was just the
refs not happen so well you that call on
a charge but he wasn't even close to the
circle yeah it wasn't even he's uh he
was moving he was moving and I was by
but they called it a charge but then
they over they overthrew it right that's
not a reviewable play rules are if we
are going to look at now allowed to
review the call but the his forefeet yep
- yeah - degress two feet out
that's 24 inches away it's one that's
your feet that's your feet till O'Neal
foot away right yeah but still yeah but
still I mean I don't know it really
makes it hard to I mean that's a it's a
super team
and there are a tough team to beat
anyway and you give them that much of an
advantage from officiating you like Tom
and then why am i watching us well if
the fix was in there calls would be
going for the Cavs I was there so I mean
they're definitely overmatched
that's what we're trying to say so yeah
you should hey they the Cavs need all
the help they can get exactly exactly
yep Sam's right and if they would have
won this game this series would have
been not matter you know this one one
and going to Cleveland everyone's like
well I'm what I don't give a [ __ ] about
Game three now the only thing is that
didn't the Cavs lost they were owned -
against the Raptors they were owned -
against the Celtics
they've been going home OSU different it
is different but that's I mean with the
Celtics I think I came one I didn't Game
one it didn't spiritually it did not
break LeBron now but it broke the other
11 guys well jr. Smith doesn't know what
to do it despite people saying that he's
like able to forget [ __ ] like that and
he thinks he's got a short memory I mean
he does look like so hesitant when in
that game - when he's shooting how about
the last play at the end of like the
half when he doesn't want or two of game
wanna where he like doesn't risky try to
steal the ball oh yeah and then and then
Steph Curry spins around from like he's
African he's ordering hot dogs the guy
he's stupid with us three you know the
these playoff series is Houston
Cleveland it is private school versus
public school yeah that's what this is
those guys klay Thompson Steph Curry
grew up in NBA gyms yeah yes they've
been taught how to shoot by NBA gulches
well and then they signed Kevin Durant
yeah nobody talked about Durant through
the game through that series because you
tell he didn't want to play with [ __ ]
Oh with OKC yeah he's up 3-1 you can't
win one they hit some crazy shots though
there was some crazy [ __ ] going on dude
and then he goes to team he lost to up
three one guy I don't know I think
you're tinfoil Hadding punch-drunk [ __ ]
yeah all days every day
they're a percent I want to see a lady
violet where the [ __ ] is it what's down
the lane violation Johnny please Johnny
really watch it 95
oh she kinda is he's on the ward
oh that's on the fighters across did you
guys see that
let me see it's not up yet we still
don't have it up yet chill oh dude chill
all right looks good though huh all
right did you go to the hockey game
here's your wait mainstream mainstream
main screen that yet I see it I see it
oh that's not really that bad oh you're
crazy watch it again
screen put the new hand and the eye
device yeah he's got a foot planted
before the shot I'm in for sure
big time and also they review so much
[ __ ] yeah hole is their new rule in
basketball absolutely that ball still in
his hands when his left foots in the
lane raps [ __ ] and they had a new
African literally and a new crew arrests
for game 2 versus the game one keeps
awesome dude it's freak that's a wrap I
mean we agree NBA is around jumping send
me the link anyway would work so I can
see it later
hey don't yell at him when you act it
out I gotta stay hey so uh where does
Steph Curry following your greatest of
all time one I'd say number one no we're
not having this discussion why he's been
for finals in a row unheard of won three
of them if he wins fish is out and if he
wins the MVP will play with them which
is good how about this
where does best of all time discussions
rank in the all-time discussions okay I
have them at seven I have them at seven
I have the NBA discussion above boxing
box and crazy
but the NASCAR is like 12 and then like
the view Power Rankings - who's that bit
on the view the best and then I you know
my number one is fight nany faces she
makes when she's not involved in the
show I like they're obviously Romero's
[ __ ] nipple crazy how fast like I do
get like I'm not tired but yeah MBA me
did you guys see that uh or read about
that four-person tournament that almost
happened in the UFC yeah and the only
reason it couldn't do it
GSP GS pts I did I don't watch the whole
thing GSP Diaz and then khabib and
Connor and then they were gonna fight
him one year and then within one year
they were all gonna fight and then the
winners go g SP said no GSP couldn't get
healthy okay I think I would like to see
could be vs. GSP I think that's a
wonderful fun I would like to see it
could be versus Connor that's what I'd
like to see Connor versus Danny Boy from
[ __ ] Trek yeah
I'd like to see that fight I'd I see
Connor fight any I like to see kind of
fight right can we at least just get to
that two years do you know that yeah you
made a hundred million dollars like I
don't want to get punched in the face
Friday and I respect that I get that I
totally get that but still then then
just say that be that maybe I think he
has no he still talk [ __ ] about shows up
and throws [ __ ] a dolly
yeah that's cuz they were mad world
bosses you saw some real [ __ ] but don't
do that then yeah well you know it's
great day or jetski bro yeah hey dude
can we running y'all all women's
softball for a second really [ __ ]
really cheating well they're striking
the batter's box this next scene I think
that's really I mean it's gonna change a
lot of stuff yeah that's really gonna
change a lot of stuff oh we got our oh
yeah let's talk about dykes
can we talk about Milwaukee sports yeah
talk Wisconsin sports sure
a hotbed time is it is it one of the
great well the milwaukee admirals hockey
season's cooking up so obviously that's
big talk to me about packers box what's
going on I can't believe other stuff and
not the Washington Capitals the Packers
talk to me about the Capitals hey uh re
the Capitals didn't win I'll tell you
why
no wow that's ball to me the Vegas
sports book says said if the Golden
Knights won the Cup it would bankrupt
vigus because everybody just put em up
with twenty on the gold nights going
that [ __ ] all the time it ain't
happening it's so much money on
everything
Vegas loves Vegas Vegas loves do you
really watch softball no I I can always
tell when there's something more
important ah yesterday that girl make
that catch up gets a wall yeah softball
the players get more into the game than
any other sport they cheer for each
other they seem like they're really
loving it it's half beautiful women and
half bull dykes and the reason the bull
dykes are there this is half beautiful
women it is a [ __ ] great way to watch
they really seem like they're not what
the chick we're in [ __ ] football
helmet stadium was empty it's
self-contained softball nice I saw some
highlights of women's lingerie football
I don't know why this is in Vegas why
isn't this bigger women's lingerie
football and they're getting rid of this
all about the hits dude look at the hits
big hit these girls like they're all
like they're all like the CrossFit but
do I sound like this [ __ ] my lesbian
friends all watch this but I'll have any
straight guy friends watch this but you
would be the one friend
I don't watch anything I just like all
that in with the biggest clique you've
ever seen in your life that's not that
big I mean for a [ __ ] it is pretty big I
mean who is in the stands watching this
ship nobody I saw you want a pan across
the crowd and I try to do play-by-play
they wouldn't let me yeah Mike at one
hand and
you know what else in the other there's
anybody in the stands third and two but
I'm doing fourth and inches in the booth
that was great it was so funny that's
why you're fast
that's why you're fast
can we get any shots of the crowd course
not there's tens of people there what I
love people what a pass that was ten
zone like I love the coaches come on
guys time work these nuts yeah
all right linemen we need you in better
shape you're misunderstanding the little
brass man at the [ __ ] lingerie [ __ ]
Bowl Hoffa D tell you right tackle that
she needs to get down to 130 made you to
bulk up and get up geez
via that's the Russell Wilson of [ __ ]
the woman's lingerie ball you mean she
can't get a concussion cuz oh look at
that boom concussed in her vagina the
doctor always goes dude doctor it's my
knee let me look at this yeah yeah let
me poke it I'm starting wide receiver is
questionable with a UTI the best part
the lingerie Bowl is like you get to
meet the players at Spearmint Rhino when
they're dancing after sweating in those
underwear would give you like a yeast
infection UTI by the way well Sam but
they're on a team under say a hose down
area where they can hose it down oh no
they got a Gatorade thing where they
just hose it are you telling me that
electrolytes there you go electrolyte
little Gator right on your vagina's
girls will be fine
doesn't matter if you're on your period
we've got this all right guys would you
put your vajayjays need is a lot of
electrolytes the entire don't dump them
on your crotch is like coach won the
game
hey team taking me suck my dick on your
knees mouths open the referee after that
plate just
tucked a dollar into the quarterbacks
jockstrap like slave okay you run
outside my little [ __ ]
come on that's so [ __ ] funny dude
that's so funny they don't throw flags
they make it rain penalty outside so we
have offsides Sam is requesting another
shower timeout this is eighth of a game
he has nine left what teams are there
I've Mayall him one city it doesn't
matter anyone there's like come on the
standing business model it's the
Atlantic um dumpsters versus the Chicago
[ __ ] and my favorite food Oh is how
they are there are I also my favorite
team is Los Angeles lying [ __ ] the
Baltimore charm
it's a Baltimore backstabbers clay can't
condone this the Cleveland climbers that
the the the comedy store's website is
dumb yeah you know why still cause tick
hackers ticket what is it ticket fly
just died surround the light it's good
guys but who do they partner what ticket
fly is that who it is yeah they got
hacked by apparently anonymous by
Russians oh is that what it was no I
don't know Jodi was telling me that it
was anonymous like there was an
anonymous face on tick many who would go
to take a fly that look you know we are
anonymous we don't forget how much you
charges for tickets to Owen go Boinga so
then now anybody associated with ticket
flies [ __ ] is completely ass no I heard
it because
women are one line up so they have
[ __ ] actors who wanted their
accountant did it laughs Emma's
Hatcher's that's why I no longer a
Bowles never gone down that web sites
never been taken be over under for
feminists hackers is it zero
can you imagine even I'm a girl with the
dragon tattoo she's a female in a movie
it sounds like you believe your
arguments trailed off pretty strong
there did you read the book yeah yeah
it's good yeah it's really good I
enjoyed it that chick likes afar I do
not have proof of this it's just a [ __ ]
we should throw in the [ __ ] female
football league yeah dude that was a fun
movie fun movie fun fun i laughter letõs
never acted better hey guys what would
it take to get a face tattoo cuz that's
pretty popular now got a face tattoo
would you get buddy I get your face on
mine you get my face on your face yeah
where would on my face
don't Adam's apple please canal I really
want your face over my face like we're
laying out like a mask like face off
awesome face on all my life this is a
true story I saw a guy with a face thank
you for validating okay I saw a guy with
a you know he's got a head like a
shitload of tattoos couple face tattoos
swear to God right where his mustache
ago said [ __ ] eaters
wow what a commitment to [ __ ] up
every wedding and everything yeah I
would love to see that job interview so
why do you want to work at Starbucks I
love to serve people and I love coffee
and I've always loved your coffee and I
want to serve people like that ruins
every wedding every Christmas every
Thanksgiving dinner it's like hey honey
where we putting your cousin [ __ ] eater
can we put him at the table oh that's it
right there
yeah was it [ __ ]
then that's not bad to have a nose
tattoo that says I smell [ __ ] and
then on his forehead grandpa you know
that guy does he lives for today 14 and
he's a grandpa well I mean maybe it's an
homage
he lives for today for sure that guy
doesn't worry about tomorrow or how he's
gonna pay his bill
that guys like today's today today I
have a all I smell [ __ ] who did all
this because of one little swastika
today now I think that's a guy that got
too drunk at a party and fell asleep and
his roommate is a tattoo artist you
would wait yeah you gotta get ready for
guys helpful Honda's guys showed up guys
it's me Rick from helpful Honda and
don't ever fall asleep when your
roommate has a tattoo gun hey I was just
supposed to give someone a gift because
there are kids with cancer [ __ ] teddy
bears now I woke up with skull [ __ ]
around my face today lemonade's on the
house I'm from Honda guys I'm gonna do
two weeks off the showroom floor someone
raped tattooed my head two weeks I don't
think I'm in sell material now that's
just ironic
yeah there has to be kind of like our I
mean I will do it because your ping
yeah I'm just I have to say this just
because nobody's ever had [ __ ] eater
put on their lip before yeah but you're
sure sure sure you sure you won what is
that one oh dude
how is that like a Blue Man Group from
your show that Dave cross what is Dave
testing hearing that's a good down there
was that a Reading Rainbow on his
favorite Kreischer over over down down
that one yeah who's that hate Fletcher a
bag of bets where he had to turn his
head into a globe his eyelid sealed shut
by piercing that guy really loves
Playhouse and his favorite player was
Oh her Globa yeah I like it oh my god he
got it [ __ ] dude yes he got his clip
pierced through his eyelid he got a
Prince Albert on his return Yvonne right
there yeah what Silvan do to his face a
man just trying to get him tattoos
homeboy oh no see Candace you can't put
tattoos on babies so you were acting
really crazy before when we suggest that
the [ __ ] stamp or where right there
hello you hello kitty these girls are
all pretty look at that that's like that
will haunt you nightmares
I betcha my job man I bet your vagina's
perhaps oh good I accidentally [ __ ] a
Star Wars character last night not sure
how bigger two teeth in her vagina
that's right
what up get into my eyes my fellow on
but I just think maybe he's gonna go
with it spell it like three is how I'm
gonna do it
what's your name I've ever been there
concert baby I summon Kimmel homoerotic
dude just gave Mexicans on ecstasy
jerking each other off that is called
Mex to see Wow
oh is that the Hollywood Bowl oh yeah
that's the one I was at I'm like what
the [ __ ] is up with these kids they were
there before I forget I ran into gay
Jesus on the way and he wanted to show
me tell you how he was really upset he
couldn't be here well I mean when
they're all Romero was the original
origin of that and now he's fighting
this weekend in smite I'll be real fun
let's read some five-star reviews so fun
it's my favorite yeah
ah I'm odd look him up see it went dead
sighs I know I mean that's as good as
having a cute up I guess guys's they're
still fighting any shirt
yeah yeah we need to make new shirt hey
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
have the fans draws shirts and if we
like them we'll turn them into shirts go
to all things all comedy tees guys I
would like a shirt sent to me it's been
like a year guys semen awesome
five star reviews from Kevin Chewbacca
love the banter and the coverage on
Corey five star reviews absolutely hello
thank you damn it here's a good one
[ __ ] David do sports fans
setting off five stars thank you we're
gonna get in trouble
love me some punch-drunk spores from
it's not a lot well done podcast shakes
me maybe we should have another meeting
see if they don't pitch from Nathan nine
one six love it Triple E for the wins
thank you shows are happening right now
Sam is thanking everyone that's ever
said he is great and Ari is wiping his
[ __ ] and showing it just like Oh
Triple E you're killing it love the game
thank you live David one listener triply
female leave a five-star review and we
will read it
love Sammy guys that's our that's our
new segment called never again Sam will
read five star reviews and Arie will
wipe his ass and show it and then
everybody else is just kind of caught in
the wash yeah well there's not a lot to
say when that's going on respect that I
do respect sir so that's it guys so guys
yeah thanks for listening to another a
bunch of Gary great to have you back
thank you its Gareth a and then please
watch out everybody please watch and
support the rest of development he's the
new senior executive executive priest
support Gary that's right section Gareth
they get it right producer this is why
he can't hang out with us on Saturdays
he's way too successful no you
completely unemployed now yeah it's true
he's always employed now did you have
family to to also no I actually was able
to dodge that bullet yeah a lot of
people behind the scenes in the like
writing room we got your a joke that
happened yeah no I mean after working
your entire life on something like this
thing and then have an interview you
know seemingly derail a lot of it great
with that
I like thanks for singing i watch all of
it
draw us t-shirts draw something cool
based on the show and we will put it and
we'll make t-shirts thank you guys for
tuning and we'll see you at the sycamore
Tavern comes out a night